when i was young there was a fella uh
by went by the name of jacques
de gautier
and he was from tamiskaming quebec
and jacques de gautier he was a fella
that
really thought and he was smart you know
he was our hope i guess
and he uh he was while i was scrambling
to get out of high school
jacques
i think you just changed his last name
well you know a man grows he
[Applause]
but this is the point yeah you know he
went to mcgill university and he got
three degrees by golly
and he went to the over across the pond
to the fellas with cambridge and he even
stood up to them and we thought boy he's
going to be the next
we had jean-marchan
pierre trudeau the three wise men of
quebec by god
jacques de gatino was going to be the
next give me the next gun yeah
but he vanished and i met him uh
i started to do stand-up and and travel
from here to there
and to here again and uh one
one time i was in uh niagara falls and
uh by
uh gosh i went over to the uh sea world
there you know how they have the sea
world
you know with the different fish you
know
i didn't know that but okay yeah yes
seaworld i've been there many times okay
so i was checking out the beluga whales
and stuff and i look over
and who do you think i see i hope it's
that guy no
it was uh it was just an attendant but
uh
but he showed me to the place i wanted
to see which is where they feed the
the little baby dolphins because i love
dolphins you know
and who do i see there but jacques de
geano
and here he is he's feeding the baby
dolphins
and i go up to him and i go get him
i feel shame for you you were our hope
you were to go to canada uh
canada's nation's capital of ottawa
and you you were to be a great man
jacques gatineau
and we were all you know we pinned our
all of olive this
gaming quebec pinned our hopes on you
now that's a that's a hell of a burden
for a man to have a town's hope pinned
on them isn't it
it is a lot big burden so he was feeding
these baby
dolphins you know and i said i'm ashamed
of you jacques zagato
you could have done so many great things
and he said well
he said i think i'm serving a youthful
porpoise now i believe
[Applause]
that
no no
i knew that was going to happen i knew
that
you don't encourage that it's like that
was a 40-minute story
it's like somebody's beautiful pointless
youthful
purpose yes not pointless i don't know
good god i know that was that was way
out alive
criticize oscar pistorius it's like
somebody's saying i got to show you
something they kick in a four mile hike
to show you a dog turd
look at it okay
well there's your reel for cbs
we're getting into the left movement
we're getting this right to last moon
i gotta have him you want to see that
every night less
this guy's got your goodness more
quebecois humor
[Laughter]
i love you